foreign
[Music]
love this Kingfisher blue
or try not to get blood on it
[Music]
so busy time then for your president
things he couldn't make it
[Music]
I assure you this is a priority for the
president we don't want to undermine
your Authority in the region we want to
enhance it
we see you as a true visionary
oh
my people need to be respected and they
will be
first
we need you to demonstrate credibility
to us
trustworthiness
[Music]
all we are doing is realizing Audrey our
dream of a new Europe
Without Limits I do apologize to you not
to me you hog apologize to my people
without cruelty [__] stinking [__]
there are times when one must choose the
hardest Road
I've chosen that road
and I have done so in the name of
Liberty
okay sure if you like
I do like